[Music]
meet JD McCreary the ten-year-old
singing sensation who nearly stole the
show at the Grammys performing with
childish gambino
[Music]
how'd it feel being up there sharing the
stage with Donald Glover and also
performing in front of that kind of
crowd oh that was just awesome I'm just
so glad that everybody supported me and
everybody like turned out with a good
reaction and I really think Donald
Glover childish gambino because he's the
best
were there any nerves right before the
performance no no I just felt really
confident no surprise there
JD says he's been singing since he was
two the California native recently
showed off his chops on Ellen
[Music]
and how's this for the circle of life JD
will reunite with his Grammys pal Donald
Glover in the Lion King live adaptation
as young Simba what was your reaction
when you got the part I was so stoked
that's just so amazing like I freaked
out yeah cuz I'm on a Disney movie I am
one of those people that's right
that's crazy the thing that I'm most
looking forward to is just seeing
everybody's reaction I want I want to
react to it
because I only got a little preview I'm
not gonna spoil it for you guys but it's
amazing it's turning over we'll have to
wait until july 2019 to see it for now
you can catch JD on Tyler Perry's the
pains on own and of course be on the
lookout for more music how would you sum
up what's been going on with you in your
life these last couple of years oh man
it's just blessing I already thanked God
for all this